Good morning.
You are watching Netflix's anime stage.
We returned to the stage of AnimeJapan after two years.
The first RED STAGE is
Netflix Anime Mega-rich stage in AnimeJapan 2021,
and I'm your host today,
NHK announcer, Hisanori Yoshida. Nice to meet you.
First, it's Netflix Anime's latest information. There really is a lot.
We have Netflix's Anime Chief Producer,
Mr. Taiki Sakurai, to share it with us.
A great lineup of guest will come in the second half,
so please stay tuned.
Mr. Sakurai, thanks for coming today.
-Looking forward.
-Okay.
About the one-minute promo video just now,
there were so many anime featured that I even lost count.
A huge number of anime will be streamed on Netflix in 2021, right?
Yes, actually, this year, there will be about 40…
Netflix Original Anime streamed.
It's double the number of last year's?
That's right. The number of anime is double of last year's,
every week… Considering there are 12 months in a year,
we have 48 anime streamed every week.
Oh, it's almost like that?
It's like that.
Every week, not one after next,
a whole series is streamed and there are 40.
In terms of episodes, there probably are hundreds of them
streamed on Netflix this year, right?
That's right.
This time, I've already been told to hurry up at this point.
That's right, we'll introduce the featured anime on Netflix.
Among them, we'll first introduce three anime
-with Mr. Sakurai.
-Thank you.
First, these two featured anime are two brand new series.
The first one is
Yasuke, which got everyone talking after its still picture was released.
This is the anime.
Today, the character designer Mr. Takeshi Koike,
has finished its special artwork.
Please have a look.
Yes, this key visual is an impressive one.
What do you think, Mr. Sakurai?
Every part is so expressive, I am speechless.
Yes, speaking of Mr. Koike,
people who like anime, especially anime movies,
I think many of them can't look away from Mr. Koike's works.
Mr. Koike designed the characters,
and the world expressed here is
an age of warring states with robots and magic mixed together.
To protect Saki, a girl who has a mysterious power,
from evil forces,
Samurai Yasuke picks up his sword again to fight the evil.
This fantasy period drama is produced
by Mr. LeSean Thomas and MAPPA.
Like Mr. Koike, Mr. LeSean Thomas has also
produced some pop anime for Netflix so far.
I think he is a very talented person.
He just loves anime,
and he has moved to Japan.
-Oh, has he?
-Yes, he lives in Japan.
He does this to be a producer here.
He spends a lot of time on it, like he stays at MAPPA all the time.
Also, speaking of MAPPA,
anime fans in Japan know the quality of their work is high,
and everybody knows the studio.
Obviously, MAPPA is a Japanese animation studio.
If Mr. LeSean Thomas has moved to Japan,
will he communicate, in English basically?
Yes, he loves Japan and anime, but he can't speak Japanese.
-Is that so?
-Yes.
That's why when we first go to talk to MAPPA,
we said if possible,
we'd like LeSean to be the producer, but he couldn't speak Japanese.
-You went to talk to them?
-Yes, I did.
When I told Mr. Otsuka…
-Their CEO.
-Yes, the CEO, Mr. Otsuka.
-He said it was quite interesting.
-What?
He said it was interesting instead?
Yes, because it wasn't done before.
He said it's good the producer didn't speak the same language.
Then, of course Jake acted as our interpreter,
he's our unsung hero too.
Something difficult like that is also interesting,
and they see it as a challenge.
MAPPA has a spirit like that,
I think it's the motivation that makes them unstoppable like this.
This just occurred to me,
that if the original series is created by Netflix,
the whole world can watch it.
Part of it makes me feel that animation
is borderless in the first place.
-That's right.
-Yes.
So, about Yasuke.
It's brand new,
so I think viewers can enjoy both its character design and its world.
Netflix's original anime series Yasuke
will premier April 29 worldwide exclusively on Netflix.
The implication sounds even more profound.
Then, the next one, Eden, is also a brand new series.
The date of streaming has also been scheduled.
Eden is a sci-fi fantasy, which talks about how Sara,
a girl raised by two robots, stands against the world.
We have the latest video released today,
let's watch it now.
Human language.
There is a human in this world.
What would you like to do?
Eliminate them.
No one must know there is a human here.
Humans are considered to be bad.
Sara!
Did the recon squad find out about this place?
What are you going to do?
Stop Zero!
Zero, are you fully recharged?
Humans will destroy the world.
They are evil.
Humans are not harmful!
Sara is a very good human.
Stop!
Why do you hate humans so much?
To create a perfect world,
humans are a hindrance.
It can't be…
Part of the anime is cute and part of it is serious.
Yes, the story is about Sara from her childhood till she grows up.
You'll see various sides of her.
Okay, when we talked about Yasuke just now,
we said the production team was international,
but Eden's is even more international.
Yes, producer Justin was my colleague
when I worked at Production IG.
This is a project he wanted to do at that time,
so we thought we might as well do it, and started it.
-Justin is a dreamer…
-I see.
He thought if he gathered the most talented people from the world,
then he could create the best work.
So we got Taiwan's animation studio,
China's art company,
music composer from Australia…
We gathered them one by one.
That's how the team was formed.
This must be a project structure that is only possible nowadays.
Actually, after this,
Miss Marika Kohno, who plays Sara,
will come as a guest and talk to us,
and we'll talk about it again later.
Netflix Original Anime Series, Eden,
will premier May 27 worldwide exclusively on Netflix.
Now, I'll introduce one more anime with Mr. Sakurai.
Let's first watch its promo video, which is first released today.
Thirteen one-on-one matches
between gods and men will take place
in what is called
"Ragnarok."
You wish not to stand in the same ring as me?
Are you perhaps
scared?
There is no one in this world who can rival me!
I have one request.
Do not die.
You're a nasty one, aren't you?
Don't look at me, you perverted old man.
For the first time in millennia, my blood is running hot.
I'm getting excited.
File number one.
It's sour.
Ganryu is still evolving.
Sounds like fun.
I'm so jealous of that human.
This is a fight for the soul.
Crush him.
They're all trash.
Wow, it makes me excited!
-It's great.
-It's great, right?
The manga series started in 2018 in Monthly Comic Zenon,
over six million copies of the popular manga were sold
and it's finally animated.
The world's god representatives
fight against human representatives
in 13 one-on-one matches to decide humanity's fate,
in the battle action anime.
How can you not be excited?
The cast is amazing as well.
It's a great lineup.
The protagonist, who proposed to hold the matches,
is the eldest of 13 Valkyrie siblings… well, sisters.
Not just Ms. Miyuki Sawashiro, who plays Brunhilde,
many people will go, "Wow!" when they see the names of the cast.
It's like one-to-one matches between Japan's voice actors.
In Warner Bros. Japan Anime's live streaming held on March 28,
Ms. Miyuki Sawashiro,
Mr. Tomokazu Seki and Mr. Hikaru Midorikawa
talked about Record of Ragnarok's appeal
and streaming information.
For more details, please check out
Warner Bros. Japan Anime's official twitter.
Anyway, Mr. Sakurai,
Netflix really loves producing pure martial arts anime,
like Baki and Kengan Ashura.
-They are really popular.
-Is that so?
They are very popular.
That's why we'd like to produce anime
packed with action in the future too.
Like The Witcher, Spriggan,
we have lots of action-packed anime coming up in the future,
please look forward to it.
On the other hand, Netflix also produces cute anime like Aggretsuko,
there are actually a lot.
We want to make cute ones too.
Okay, we've got a large variety of anime, so please look forward.
Netflix Original Anime Series, Record of Ragnarok
will premier in June worldwide only on Netflix.
That concludes the introduction of Netflix's featured anime.
Mr. Sakurai will leave the stage for now,
and our other guests will come on stage.
-Thank you, Mr. Sakurai.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you for your patience.
Next, let's welcome the main actors
from Netflix's featured original anime
and interview them about the highlight of the anime.
Please let me introduce our guests.
First, it is this gentleman.
This cozy comedy anime shows
the daily life of a legendary ex-yakuza,
who lives as a househusband.
Playing protagonist Tatsu in The Way of the Househusband,
Mr. Kenjiro Tsuda.
Hello, I am Kenjiro Tsuda. I play the Immortal Dragon, Tatsu.
Nice to meet you.
The key visual of the anime next to you is impressive.
-It's strong.
-Nice to meet you.
-Same here.
Next, a girl raised by two robots
stands against the world in the sci-fi fantasy.
This is Miss Marika Kohno who plays the protagonist Sara in Eden.
Hello, I play Sara in Eden.
I am Marika Kohno. Thanks for having me today.
Nice to meet you.
The key visual is totally different from The Way of the Househusband.
Yes, it is a precious one.
Yes, the little girl in the middle is Sara?
Yes, it is her.
Next.
Zombies appear in the White House.
Expect the largest scale ever seen
from the first serial CG drama of the RESIDENT EVIL series,
RESIDENT EVIL: Infinite Darkness.
Playing the protagonist, Leon, is Mr. Toshiyuki Morikawa.
Yes, everyone. Good morning.
I am Toshiyuki Morikawa, and I play Leon. Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you.
It is that RESIDENT EVIL series.
On top of that, it is a serial CG drama.
Yes, it's the first one.
Yes, I can't contain my excitement,
but let's talk about each anime now.
We'll start from Mr. Kenjiro Tsuda's The Way of the Househusband.
Okay.
First, the promo video is released,
and it's already very funny.
-Thank you.
-We'd like to show you that.
Please watch the trailer of the anime.
Once,
there was a legendary yakuza,
feared in the world of organized crime.
The Immortal Dragon.
However, one day,
the man vanished without a trace and is now…
Occupation?
Full-time househusband.
For the family I love,
I will weather the Way of the Househusband!
This is uncut, 100 percent hand-sewn.
Come on, just buy it.
I won't buy you games if you act like a spoiled brat!
Hamburger meal.
Don't you know light and dark laundry doesn't mix!
Don't mess with color transfer!
Why aren't you attacking the corner?
Boss!
Huh?
Why'd you quit being a yakuza?
Hey!
I'm going to protect my own in my own way.
You forgot your lunch!
Daily chores just became a little more fun
in this cozy comedy
exclusively available on NETFLIX.
NETFLIX is seriously raking in the dough.
The Way of the Househusband.
I'll pay whatever it takes. Just prepare the goods.
Also, could you make a point card for me?
After you watch the promo video…
First, Miss Kohno and Mr. Morikawa,
who also watched it, are laughing.
-I'm very happy.
-It's amazing!
It even gets the client, Netflix, involved.
-Yes.
-I've never seen that before.
"It's raking the dough."
Everything is different from its appearance.
It's attractive.
-Yes!
-Tatsu is cute, indeed, isn't he?
He is cute!
The moment I saw him making the character lunch box,
I thought, I wanted a dad like him.
Want a dad like him?
-I want a dad like him!
-You want a dad like him?
I do!
He does chores at home properly.
He does them perfectly.
-He is an accepting person.
-Yes, indeed.
This key visual too, it's a gangster and a character lunch box.
-Yes.
-That's what the character is like.
The original manga of this anime is very popular to begin with.
I looked up who the producer is, it's Ms. Chiaki Kon.
-Yes, it's her.
-Like Nodame Cantabile…
Nobody can make gags in daily life funnier than Ms. Kon.
J.C.STAFF does the animation production,
so there's a huge gap between its scariness and its cuteness,
-I think.
-Yes.
First, as a viewer, Mr. Tsuda,
I assume you've watched part of it,
what do you think?
-It is extremely funny.
-Yes.
It made me excited even when I watched it just now.
It really is stupid.
It is so stupid,
but there are many things you can learn from it.
-Learn from it?
-Things that are common for househusbands.
When you do the laundry,
he goes, "You use this drug… this white powder?"
-He says "white powder" in that voice?
-Yes, that's right.
But he does tell you things useful for…
househusbands…
-Tips?
-There are many tips in the anime.
It's useful in that sense.
Yes. But Mr. Tsuda, you've originally
done the promo video of the original manga series,
and a live action version of it.
You've been playing Tatsu for a while.
Yes, I've been involved in various pieces of work.
There must be many things about Tatsu,
but what is important when you play him?
Ah…
He is quite a serious person, despite his looks.
I see!
He is very strict and serious about being a househusband.
I guess it's the gap between them.
The gap, as Miss Kohno said.
-The gap is really…
-It's a huge difference.
You can see how interesting it is everywhere.
And if he intimidates you in Kansai dialect,
-it startles you at first.
-Yes.
Mr. Tsuda, you came from the Kansai region…
Yes, from Osaka.
What do you think about the language Tatsu speaks?
Well, you can see the power of his Kansai dialect everywhere
in the anime,
like the very localized "don't be a chicken."
There are words you don't hear often too.
But when I talked to the manga artist of the original manga series,
he also lets Tatsu say many things that aren't Kansai dialect,
so it's like the series' own Kansai dialect.
Its own Kansai dialect? A new language?
Yes, it's Kansai dialect in the Way of the Househusband's world.
But everyone laughed very hard when we recorded it,
and we had a lot of fun.
Yes, it must've been hard for you to contain your laughter.
We said we could do it forever.
-Forever? Because it's so much fun?
-Yes.
-You want to stay in its world forever?
-Yes, it's really enjoyable.
It's coming soon.
Netflix Original Anime Series The Way of the Househusband
premiers April 8 worldwide exclusively on Netflix.
I wonder how the world will react.
-Exactly!
-Really.
When I filmed the live action promo video,
I directed it and played the main character.
There were many comments left by people overseas.
Wow!
In a very traditional English dictionary,
-the word "yakuza" is there as it is.
-Yes.
-This must be a style unique to Japan.
It is a comedy like this.
-Please look forward to it.
-Thank you.
Next, I'd like to move on to Eden,
which features Miss Marika Kohno as the protagonist.
Okay.
This is an anime you had spent a long time working on,
you did a so-called prescoring once, didn't you?
That's right. It's a new anime without an original story,
so we recorded our lines for them to make the animation.
We recorded our lines without any picture,
in the form of prescoring.
You recorded it properly again after it's polished.
That's right. We recorded the same scene again and again,
the CG of the drawings was being finished gradually,
and we've been watching it together.
The anime was made in such an elaborate way,
so we'll watch the video…
It's an existing video, so please say whatever you think.
Sure!
Please have a look at the video.
Mr. Sakurai said a company in China drew the background,
its texture is a bit different from the artwork of Japan.
That's right.
When I saw the colored drawings,
I thought they were drawn in quite a pop way.
And Sara. This is the character you play, Miss Kohno?
-Yes.
The movement of the CG is very vivid.
It is stylish.
Even when I read the script,
I already thought the character moved a lot.
You can see moments when her facial expressions change in CG,
so I'm happy.
And Sara is the first person identified in this world for the time being.
Sara is the only one.
That's right, in this world,
Sara is the only human in this world,
that's the moment the story begins.
It is also a big secret of this world.
An evil-looking person just showed up.
Evil-looking person… robot?
-Which one? Robot, right?
-It's a robot.
The robot is played by Mr. Koichi Yamadera.
-Yes, that's right.
-Yes.
I did the recording with him.
There was a scene where Mr. Yamadera's character drank something.
-What? But he's a robot.
-But he's a robot.
He's a robot,
but there's a scene, where he chews a drink.
I guess there's a secret
-hidden in what you said.
-It's a huge secret.
-Wow…
-So, about that scene…
Yes, in that scene, I still…
I like to observe how other voice actors do the recording,
so I was watching from the back.
During rehearsal,
Mr. Yamadera actually poured water into his water bottle's cup,
actually drank it, and sighed.
He acted out the scene in the anime
before the microphone as it was.
The moment I saw it, I thought,
"Oh, it's okay to do that?"
Things that are okay to do in front of a microphone,
things I can or can't do, which I can come up with,
it's still difficult to draw the line.
In the middle of it, when I saw him drinking water…
I realized it was something allowed.
Maybe it was possible only because it was Mr. Yamadera,
but I thought it was wonderful.
Mr. Morikawa, have you actually used drinks and stuff
when you act?
-Yes, I have.
-Right?
There was a scene I had to eat bread
and talk with it in my mouth.
No matter how… If I don't put any bread in my mouth,
it doesn't sound realistic,
so I went to a convenient store to buy some bread myself,
I bought several kinds of bread to do it.
Wow! You put it in your mouth when you spoke, right?
Did you swallow it after you spoke?
What do you think I did?
I swallowed it. But just that scene…
I recorded it separately.
I recorded another scene after I swallowed it.
I see! You include so much detail when you act.
Eden was made very elaborately too.
-It's shown like that.
-Yes.
Yes.
The only human character, Sara, in Eden
-is played by Miss Kohno.
-Yes.
She first appeared as a baby,
-did you voice the baby as well?
-I did.
I played her from the moment she was born until she grew up.
According to what you said,
there probably is a big secret hidden in all episodes.
Yes, there's a big secret in Eden, which I can't talk about yet,
I hope our viewers will go on a journey with Sara.
-Go on a journey with Sara, right?
-That's right.
On May 27,
Netflix Original Anime Series, Eden,
will premier worldwide only on Netflix.
-Please look forward to it as well.
-Thank you.
I'd like to move on to our last anime today.
The last anime is
RESIDENT EVIL: Infinite Darkness.
Please first have a look at this video.
It is very suggestive and powerful.
It is.
I want to see Leon and Tatsu fight each other in a match.
They both look strong.
But really, this original series…
I think everyone knows the title of RESIDENT EVIL,
-but this is a serial CG drama.
-Yes, it is.
It's the long-awaited drama.
A serial drama with full CG animation.
I guess people all over the world are very curious
-about the story.
-Yes.
I'm curious too.
You play a character in it,
so I think you know it earlier than everyone else,
but I'll say it anyway.
Popular characters, Leon S. Kennedy, played by Mr. Morikawa,
and Claire Redfield, are the pivot of the story
that unfolds around them.
It's a horror action drama.
When I want to dig deeper now,
-there are many elements I'm curious about.
-Yes.
Right?
The information was released the other day,
you'll know after seeing this.
One of the stages of the story is the White House.
That's right. Leon was holding a gun
and rescuing someone just now.
The scene… the place was the White House.
I think everyone knows that.
As far as you can see in the teaser,
the Western-style building before that…
The Western-style building, where Claire was,
and the White House seemed to be the stage,
but actually, in RESIDENT EVIL: Infinite Darkness,
it's worldwide…
The stage is set in the whole wide world.
That's what I hope our viewers will enjoy.
But no doubt there'll be zombies if it's RESIDENT EVIL.
-That's right.
-Right?
-There will be.
If zombies show up in the White House,
the existence of humans is at risk…
It is quite serious.
-Right?
-Yeah.
What is it, Miss Kohno? You suddenly chuckled.
Well, I absolutely love the series itself,
and I've been playing its video games,
but the moment it becomes a drama…
What is it? When the zombies attack,
in a sense, I'm not the player anymore,
so I can watch it objectively.
I can relax a bit and watch over Leon.
I can relax and just simply think,
-"how interesting," so I smiled.
-I see.
But doesn't it make you nervous
when you watch someone play RESIDENT EVIL?
You can see the official video
RESIDENT EVIL: Infinite Darkness.
That's right.
There is one more point. Speaking of Leon, you'd think,
"Wait, did he wear a suit?"
-You do, right?
-Right?
Well, actually, in terms of timeline,
it's several years after Resident Evil 4.
-Oh, is that so?
-It is.
That's why he should be working as an agent
directly under the United States, probably.
"Probably…" It's "probably" now, right?
That's what it is.
I also mentioned this right at the beginning,
that this is a serial CG animation.
Since the so-called subscription service
became available in the world,
serial dramas have been a big hit in the world, right?
RESIDENT EVIL is now one of them.
It is the type that makes you want to know what happens next.
Mr. Morikawa, I think you already got the scripts,
did they surprise you every time?
-Actually, I haven't recorded anything.
-What?
-You haven't?
-No.
Oh, wow. That means you start at the same place as our viewers…
-The same. It's the same.
-Wow.
Well, I know more bits and pieces,
-but I can't tell you yet.
-You were told.
-So, above all…
-Yes.
-You look forward to it as a viewer?
-I'm looking forward to it.
This title is categorized as survival horror,
but there are some quite…
important development in the story too.
You're going to see the development.
I hope you'll look forward to it.
In a sense, a video game commentary by Mr. Morikawa
is going to be streamed.
I wonder. To me, playing video games is quite difficult,
so I don't know whether I can do the commentary well or not.
-But you'll play Leon this time.
-Yes.
Leon will wear a suit this time.
Usually… Well, he started as a rookie policeman,
and if I must say, he adopts a so-called…
fighting style,
but I think Leon also looks handsome in his suit,
in a dignified manner.
It has become even more thrilling.
If you want to know what the story is,
Netflix Original Anime Series
RESIDENT EVIL: Infinite Darkness
will premier in 2021 worldwide exclusively on Netflix,
-so please look forward to it this year.
-That's right.
It's been a blink of an eye,
and Netflix Anime Mega-rich stage in AnimeJapan 2021
now comes to an end.
I'd like to ask each of our guests to say a few words.
-Mr. Tsuda, please.
-Okay, thank you.
Something has been bothering me.
Leon has been pointing his gun at Mr. Morikawa the whole time.
It's true!
-He's right at that position.
-Yeah.
He warns me not to give spoilers.
That's what it is? He'll shoot you if you give any spoiler.
It's brilliant! Would you zoom in?
Brilliant.
Tatsu looks like he'd point a gun at someone.
Yeah, it's him instead.
Sorry, I just digressed.
The Way of the Househusband is really funny,
it is a useful and really wonderful anime,
so I hope you would watch it.
Thank you.
Thank you. Next, Miss Kohno, please say something.
Yes. Again, I am Marika Kohno, and I play Sara in Eden.
As you can see, this is a very precious anime,
and it is filled with love.
There are still many mysteries,
please enjoy it together with your family.
Thank you for today.
It's the second anime you worked with Mr. Irie, who directed…
-FullMetal Alchemist.
-Yes.
It's now an anime I love.
Please look forward. And Mr. Morikawa, please say something.
Okay. It will be streamed worldwide
exclusively on Netflix in 2021,
so RESIDENT EVIL fans all over the world,
I hope you will enjoy watching
RESIDENT EVIL: Infinite Darkness.
Please be patient!
It seems nothing was shot out of the gun Leon is holding.
Many other anime have been announced
as Netflix's original anime this time,
but please also look forward to
The Way of the Househusband, Eden,
RESIDENT EVIL: Infinite Darkness.
On April 4, a Sunday,
Netflix Anime Mega-Rich 2 Hour Special is scheduled.
This special program will be streamed
on Netflix Anime's official Twitter
and Netflix Anime's YouTube channel.
Details will be released on Netflix Anime's official Twitter anytime,
please check it out.
Please enjoy the mega-rich anime on Netflix this spring.
Everyone, thank you very much
for tuning in early in the morning.
Would our guest please stand up when we say goodbye,
and wave your hands?
Thank you for watching today!
Thank you!
Thank you.